grant hommage que nous pourrions rendre
à christine renom ce sera de lutter pour
nos droits et pour ceux nos élèves
christine renaud directrice d'école
s'est suicidé dans son établissement a
pantin le 22 septembre 2019 dans une
lettre
elle se disait épuisé on peut pas
exercer simultanément correctement deux
métiers celui d'enseignant dans une
classe et celui de directeur d'école en
maternelle dont le primaire le malaise
des directeurs d'école ressurgit faire
classe gérer l'administratif les parents
d'élèves
le tout pour une prime d'environ 150
euros déjà dans les années 90 la
fonction n'attire pas les enseignants
5000 postes sont vacants à l'époque il
manque de reconnaissance de temps le
fauteuil de directeur dans cette école
de vénissieux par exemple aucun
instituteurs ne voulait travailler avec
les enfants et pas assumer le travail
administratif à l'école 2000 les
directeurs sont à bout leur grève et
discrète elle et administratives
en clair l'aspect administratif de leur
travail est reléguée au second plan
ce n'est plus la priorité je crois que
larmes a préféré taux directeur pendant
l'année scolaire c'est le répondeur et
tout ce qui peut être différée dans
l'être pour garder une priorité à
l'enseignement et à la classe quelques
manifestations aussi à dieppe par
exemple ce quartier symbolise quoi mais
ça me lisent en fait toutes les
documents administratifs que nous
recevons tous les jours et que nous
devons envoyer à l'administration
ce qu'ils réclament plus de temps
consacré à la direction et une meilleure
rémunération pour se faire entendre ils
vont devoir être patient ça fait quatre
ans que ça dure et la raison est
toujours la même
toute cette semaine les directeurs mène
des actions symboliques
le mouvement dur pour se faire entendre
les directeurs organise même une quête à
strasbourg en 2005 pour doter le
ministère de l'éducation d'un sonotone
réaction sept mois plus tard le
ministère propose un protocole 15 euros
de plus par mois pour les directeurs et
surtout pour les assistés des emplois de
vie scolaire 1 par établissement pas de
quoi convaincre toute la profession l'a
embauché
et des contrats d'avenir qu'il revient
aux africains des contrats d'avenir ce
sont des personnels précaires sans
broncher conjointe et moi nous nous
demandions qui simplement des collègues
reagan
on appelle ça des brigades de
remplacement c'est-à-dire former avec
asthmatiques et les emplois de vie
scolaire ont tout de même soulagé le
travail dans les écoles leur statut a
ensuite évolué et sont devenus
auxiliaire de vie scolaire en contrats
aidés fameux contrats aidés quasi
supprimé en 2018 laissant derrière eux
une charge de travail supplémentaire
[Musique]